[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
georgia halliday loved music
she was a happy healthy teenager and
close to her family
she
sorry
she was um
amazing
she was so well liked by everybody
she
was very popular
georgia's aunt is almost lost for words
her grief raw
her anguish unimaginable
it was out of the blue
as i say she was a fit and healthy 15
year old
i think that's a shock you know i never
got over
georgia died last tuesday
just four days after testing positive
for covid
she has four younger siblings and her
little sister julie says she now cries
herself to sleep
every time someone tried to bully me she
would always be there to stand next to
me
always be there when
like anything happens nothing's the same
without her here like
no one's feeling happy anymore
georgia was a gifted kickboxer she
trained and coached with her local club
and was a role model for younger
children she's this wonderful little
student who was helping out loads and
loads of people but she was so kind and
caring and she put in that attention
into helping other people which was the
most impressive thing about her
georgia died on the day she was due to
be vaccinated
her death is a rare case the risks of
covid among children remain extremely
low
but those risks are painfully real for
georgia's family and they hope their
heartbreak will remind and reassure
young people to get vaccinated
as part of georgia's legacy we are
trying to raise awareness
of
parents and teenagers that are shunning
the vaccine
because um
if we can
if we can help save just one person's
life as a result of raising this
awareness
then george's death wouldn't have been
in vain laura bundock sky news
southampton